well Addison expect a picture-perfect
surprise yeah it's crazy fellow
tick-tock er Thomas petrol is added
again this time the 21 year old
prankster decided to pull a swift one on
Addison Rae surprising her by covering
her Jeep in photos with her rumored
onigen boyfriend
Bryce hall and Addison's reaction is
everything let's go back to the
beginning Thomas decided it was prank
o'clock the squad put in the order
oh my how many did you print went to
work pretty stellar design job here guys
oh my god this looks so good you know
what happens next
time to show Addison her new ride we
have to say sorry made her feelings very
clear but was still a good sport
even attempting to take the brightest in
mobile for a short spin do not try this
at home
brightest newsreel I can't even believe
it's possible for me right now
the car stunt is the latest puzzle piece
that has fans wondering if the tick-tock
power couple is back together it is
crazy that I'm in that position now that
people are like so curious about like
who I like I don't know it's so cool
though they've been posting tic TOCs
together and Bryce shared this photo to
his Instagram story on Thursday we
actually met in October we kind of
started hanging out more and then like
once I moved here we like start hanging
out a lot and then we got like super
close and like we were really really
really good friends yeah back in
February Addison told DT the two decided
to keep it friendly but they weren't
ruling out the possibility of getting
back together in the future we were
talking and like kind of on and off just
like trying to figure things out you
know things happen and then like we just
decided like we're better off as friends
for now because like we both have like
totally different I guess like
lifestyles right now so I think right
now we're just better off as friends and
like we both like mutually decided that
like it was kind of just a thing that we
were like you know we love each other so
much and like we love being around each
other and we're super good friends so
it's like for I guess for now it's just
best that we stay that way and like you
know we support each other 100%
[Music]